this is about the second week of this
expedition we are our third location
here my mission is to photograph the
helmet or armbands
he's hella nerd hornbills they've been
occupying these forests for thousands of
years but recently they've fallen prey
to basically human greed and this
hornbill has this really unique horn on
its head that's a solid character
material local people have been hunting
this bird for a long time and it's
somehow survived so it is learned to
avoid humans but recently there's been a
surge in demand for the carb hornbill
products in China and this has led to a
kind of industrial scale poaching with
hunters of guns and so I'm trying to
document this bird just sort of show
people what it's like to try to get some
more attention for it before it's too
late
well it's not them Chuck's howdini
isn't
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
female and the male both came to the
house cavity she had this really amazing
called the female was working on the
entrance or
there was a moment when the
he only pulled her head out and look
like they like almost like touched beaks
[Music]
at speechless
this this here it's kind of amazing
because you can see you can still see
the feathers we have here about how many
L think we have a lot of hundred a
hundred two hundred yeah these are you
know just the ones that were captured by
the authorities there are probably
thousands estimated that have been
exported from Indonesia just in the past
few years my estimation is about six
thousand helmeted hornbill has been
killed in West Kalimantan alone in 2013
alone in 2015 it's you know leap from
near threatened into the critical in
dangerous which is one step before
extinction
[Music]
this pair has likely made it for life
every year they look for a hollowed
cavity and if they find one they'll
clear it out and the female will seal
herself in sometimes 30 meters high in
the canopy
[Music]
the mail provides all the food for her
and their newborn chick until the young
birds able to fledge 150 days later
large Marvel's like this are believed to
live for 40 or maybe even up to 50 years
in the wild so killing a male phunkfist
for its horn is removing an individual
from the environment that may have funny
or 30 years of reproductive life left
so sometimes depending on when the male
is hunted if he's killed at a critical
time when the female is inside the nest
with a chick and maybe she's mole things
she can't fly and escape killing the
male might result in female and the baby
also lose in their life
[Music]
[Music]